let's finish out by having a look at
trigonometric functions now
what you're going to find is that all of
your knowledge on trigonometry all the
way back from like year 9 and 10 is
going to be sort of
prerequisite foundational knowledge for
these questions and i will bet if you're
anything like me when i was learning
this concept um you're going to go in
through this question and you're going
to realize at multiple points
oh i can't remember how to do that you
do have the knowledge you have learned
this stuff but it was a long time ago
or even it was a long time ago you
haven't practiced it recently so
you're going to call back all of that
knowledge and able to do these questions
but
for now let me show you the process for
starters
um i've got a straight integration
question okay a straight definite
integral
i want the function that if i were to
differentiate it it would land me here
sine of 2x that's how we define the
primitive right the thing you would have
differentiated
to get this okay now i know sine
comes from cosine roughly speaking but i
know there's also negatives in there
there's going to be reverse chain rule
as well so something that might help you
definitely helps me is to do a bit of
extra working over
on the side here so for instance i know
i've got that 2x in there so let's have
say for example cos of 2x what would be
the derivative of this guy
okay well i'm going to do chain rule so
inside and then outside
the inside it's going to be 2
and then the outside is going to be
negative sine
so i'm getting here minus 2 sine 2
x so in other words if i were to
integrate
minus 2 sine 2x where i would end up
is with cos 2x now this is not what i
want right i don't want to have
-2 out the front here i want just the
sine 2x all by itself so what i'm going
to do in this red working
is i'm going to divide both sides by
negative 2. so that would give me
if i can write here instead of laser
point that would give me
if i divide by negative 2 it's the same
as multiplying by negative a half
that would give me this on the left hand
side dividing by negative 2 remember
and on the right hand side it would give
me this okay
success this is what i want right this
is the thing that if i integrate it
uh sorry if i differentiate it i would
land at sine 2x
so this guy in here let me highlight it
for you in green this guy here is the
primitive
that i'm searching for so now that i've
got that in my mind and i've worked it
out on the side here
i'm ready to reapproach this integral
the primitive is this negative a half
cos 2 x from naught to
pi on 3. before i go ahead and do my
substitution
as i've done before i'm going to take
out that factor of negative 1 over 2
and that means i'm just going to be
evaluating this guy not
to pi on 3. let's see the substitution
now so
negative 1 on 2 out the front cos of 2
pi on 3 firstly and then cos of
0 secondly now this is one of those
points where you're like oh yeah this is
something i can't remember you can of
course reach for your calculator
and evaluate this straight from there
but
cos of 2.3 this is meant to be an exact
value that we actually know
and hopefully the more you do this the
more you'll actually get familiar with
the values
so if i've got this negative 1 over 2
out the front
i have to know because i've done this
question many times cos of 2 pi on 3 is
negative 1
over 2. cos of 0 when you think about
the cos graph and where it looks like it
starts from
up high and then it goes down like a
valley right so
i'm going to have starting at the top a
minus 1 that's the the top
part of the range now i'm ready to do
the arithmetic so
negative 1 over 2 negative a half take
away
1 that's going to be negative 3 over 2
my negatives cancel and i get 4
on the denominator so that's what this
looks like and you can see how i had to
call on some of my previous knowledge
in order to do the integration part of
this